women you're about to meet are proof
that if you dream big
and live fearlessly the sky's the limit
for whatever you really want to do
literally i got the honor to fly with an
all-female crew with the united states
air force
at joint face mcguire dix lakehurst
on a refueling mission over 30 000 feet
in the air i know talk about
girl power check this out
[Music]
hi i'm drew i'm colonel michelle avianco
i'm the 305th operations group commander
it's so nice to meet you hi drew i'm
colonel mary teeter and i'm the 35th
maintenance group commander
we have a great team it's very rare that
you see two female 06s that
uh any girl that's out there that'll
watch her segment they can see it they
can dream it and they know that they can
do it and i'm really really excited you
said you are a thrill seeker so how do
you
feel yes how do you feel about being
about 12 feet behind another aircraft
is that a couple hundred knots yeah of
course of course
it's big i'm at charlie's angels we like
to get on the wings of the flying plane
and jump out with the map perfect
parachute
so if you're ready let's go yeah thank
you
hi guys happy to see you so these are
all of our aerial port airmen and
they're responsible for passenger and
cargo movement
they lined up to see you come in and
give you a wave formal and
fancy i'm so like groovy and casual
but tell me one detail about yourself
move here
two years ago like snowboarding i like
to cook i like to collect cookbooks me
and wife have a kid about every 10 years
so that's our superpower
so nice to meet you too let's get you
briefed up let's get you ready to fly
i'm captain nicole mccarthy i'll be your
kc-10 instructor pilot for today
and that's the air refueling aircraft so
we actually give off the gas to the c-17
and i'm captain caitlin stark caxiola
and i'll be the c-17 aircraft commander
so i'll be the jet that's receiving the
fuel today i am your weather forecaster
for the flight today
current conditions are quite cloudy with
more clouds coming in just a little bit
around
uh landing time are we going to hire
turbulence are we going to get some
stomach
jumps butterflies no no ma'am
little to no turbulence expected i am so
excited for this flight mission
man one last thing before you go to make
your flight suit more official so you're
not going out completely nameless
we have some patches for you this is so
cool
this is so me perfect
[Music]
ma'am you're ready to fly let's step out
and get going all right ma'am
hi i'm mary claire so nice to meet you
what made you want to fly in these
planes getting to travel
and getting to participate in a lot of
different missions
yeah so i've gotten to go to about 40
different countries in this plane
what are we going to be doing in here
today so we're going to get fuel from
the other plane
okay great so we'll fly up right behind
them and connect
that's so rad i can't wait okay well
then i guess i'll see you across the way
maybe yes
we need to make sure that everything is
put on safely and refreshing yeah
with this thing flying around exactly
so we use these big chains and devices
do you actually want to take a go at it
sure yeah i don't need gloves you do
so they're your gloves you have a belt
for you so push down on this lever back
here on the back oh yeah
yeah and then twist it towards you there
we go and then so that's
locking it into place
[Music]
pilot you are cleared off thanks for
your help
[Music]
that was so cool
we just wanted you to have something to
take back to them to show them that no
matter what
they can do anything thank you so much
you guys my
olive and my frankie nailed it best
present ever
thank you thank you thank you thank you
to the members
of the three of this air mobility wings
and some of them are here now hello
oh my gosh i just want to say i had the
greatest day with you
thank you so much for
allowing not just myself but this whole
show
into your world i have the patches out
of myself olive and frankie i also have
my special
other wings and i just have them all
over our apartment and so i've been
thinking about you guys every single day
since that mission
and you are just forever in my heart
and mind and i want to really really
really tell you
what a special experience that was thank
you for allowing me
to do that
maybe i'll catch you on another flight
someday
thank you so much for your service and
please thank all the other members who
aren't here today that i had such a
pleasure speaking with not only did i
love the flight so much but hearing
everybody's story and a detail about
their lives
was such a highlight for me so thank you
thank you so much again